I could have sworn they fried reindeers
or something dude reindeers horses
Colleen can you confirm yeah I ride
nieces all the time okay really really
you shoot one you shoot one we're eating
for forever
[Music]
so the National Park Service has
encouraged folks to never push a slower
friend down during bear encounters how
often does this happen this happens a
lot Oh you mean like to make a sacrifice
like push him well so you ever come
across a bear right yeah and then it's
like hey your friend is being slower
like don't push the slower friend down
like as a joke oh why would that be a
joke in front of a bear they're gonna
get eaten anyways right yeah they're
pretty slow yeah yeah and don't remain
friends afterwards that that is an
option well are we supposed to be slow
and run with them slow down like are we
supposed to encourage I mean I don't get
what don't you get it makes total sense
to everyone else what are we supposed to
do it's just like just remain just
remain I'm gone keep the same Pace okay
I'll be out of there yeah but am I
supposed to like go back are you faster
than the bear
do you know how fast bears go they're
pretty fast they're off are they they
could climb yeah they can climb oh see
that's where that's where they get me
yeah I'm probably faster than them and
bears can hover for at least a couple
seconds but you know what though people
don't talk about this yeah with bears
you just run zigzags they can't follow
that is that right unless have you ever
I thought that was a gunman that's both
guns Bears coyotes up the bear they
don't know how to zigzag I'm running I'm
going yeah but don't do that double move
okay is that a snake snakes will follow
you yeah they'll follow you they're like
this is helping me get faster yeah snake
straight line I thought you're supposed
to go toward a bear when you see one
you're like [__] you gotta go
towards it and then you yeah yeah yeah
if you have a basketball you think
basketball just dribble around it's a
broken bare ankles yeah yeah yeah so
something that happens that actually
happens in life that the National Park
Service is kind of
making a joke out of is when you're in a
moment with a bear you have a tendency
of fight or flight and some people have
been known to just shove their friend to
the ground to like wow get away that's
[__] up wow what kind of what that's
not fight or flight that's like that's
like sacrifice yeah sacrifice yeah yeah
sacrifice yeah human sucker what do you
even call that that's the next level
dude because there's a fight there's
flights and then there's I think that's
a form of flight
it's like a yeah it's like a sub
category yeah yeah it's like a knife
it's a sneaky piece of [__] yeah they
probably accidentally sprayed themselves
but the weird thing is if they're
telling you to not do that that means
there's a lot of people that do it but
also I don't think that would stop
someone from doing that yeah if they had
it in their heart but they they didn't
they need an alternative is there any
alternative to that
um don't be the slower friend yup see so
that's why I'm like or do you travel in
a group of Threes where Aces make sure
the third one is
even better they don't like big
creatures so you gotta learn how to do a
pyramid real quick stack on the shoulder
cheerleading classes yeah so when
there's you you chill in the party at
three and then when you see the bear you
have them jump on your [__] shoulder
and you go and then the bear goes what
the [__] but what about the girls at the
bottom of the pyramid because that's
that's probably the skin I mean her face
is history she gets clawed up
I'm on the top
you don't need to do the pyramid just
get if there's only two people just go
shoulders and then just get the big red
roll yeah yeah I would like to rent a
car please you do one of those you asked
the bear I am over age
how much bird hotel room hello Avis you
guys hike with bear mace or anything
like that is that what bear mace yeah
when you bear spray Tyson do you go to
Bear Meats
like what's Bear mates
to me you get freaked out to me I'm like
odd why do you need bear mace like you
shouldn't be able to just defend
yourself already yeah like I know karate
I don't need bear mates that's what I'm
pulling you don't keep beer yeah oh open
guard all day isn't it is it a thing to
keep bear mates for use against people
because it's stronger than just regular
clothes do dangerous too dangerous yeah
is it too dangerous it is right it's too
dangerous I've seen them I've seen a
bear cub it was about this big right
here oh [__] off the ground on the table
no that's oh
a big difference baby or to the ground
yeah
it's big
yeah so the mama was close by so we were
walking up I parked and we were walking
up uh this road that leads into a hiking
uh path and then there were three cars
lined up in the [__] baby bear was
just on top of the car just crushing the
[__] out of the hood damn [__] eating
berries or whatever the [__] he was
doing there was a ranger just like
making sure that nobody got close yeah
so they're like oh yeah just keep going
the mom's probably close by so just be
careful yeah that's the worst mom might
be tell the mom to take care of her
coffee take your [__] kid you know
because I would send a trend their way
yeah I mean I get we're in their space
and you know but nah you better get your
[__] boys
I'm about to light this [__] up yeah
straight up I'll burn my own car
somebody get your kids yeah okay I just
imagine being the hiker coming back and
then you see your whole Hood crushed and
you're like what happened hey you know
what's another animal that people don't
talk about that are also very dangerous
or moose bro what's a moose what's the
plural
is that for real yeah but we don't have
moose down here no but there was a video
in Alaska there's lady walking they're
huge and I guess the the POV is from the
car and she's yelling at the lady who's
walking like yo get out the way there's
a moose and it's giant the moon starts
running down the sidewalk and it sticks
this chick and just dips
what did she do talking [__] probably
that's what I'm saying she pushed
herself down to the ground she's like
[__] this doesn't work what are you
gonna do here's the [__] boost
there's no me
it's just you you coward yeah yeah and
he's like I'm pretty big actually you're
just alone forever yeah and she that
that moose beat the [__] out of her it's
crazy I think most are like chill yeah
but they're big [__] well in
the cartoons they always make it Rocky
Michael right he's chill no no he's not
no that was something
don't Canadian [__] right they don't
they ride those dudes can you eat oh
yeah you can yeah Canadians don't
definitely don't ride though the [__]
mounties don't they ride moose nah
they're just horses they're red horses I
think I could have sworn they [__]
ride reindeers or some [__] dude
reindeers or horses Colleen can you
confirm yeah I ride mises all the time
okay really really you shoot one you
shoot one we're eating for forever
chest freezer yeah why are you right why
do you have the red knees you don't want
to talk you want to tell everybody why
you have to ride me yeah thanks Steve
yeah just she just forgot what a deep
callback oh it's it's it's
right there in my Cranium it's it's very
present the oblongata do you want to
tell everybody
her daily moves got stolen such a bad
day my consistent moose got storage
commuter moose my Premiere mousse so the
National Park Service is being cheeky
right they're gonna be funny yeah so
people say what if you're the slower
friend what should I do and then they
say check on the Friendship before you
head into the woods they're they're kind
of being cheap having fun with it having
fun with it having a blast that's cool
it's a new age trying to get clicks I
think trying to you know drum up some
pretty modern fun shout out to their
marketing social media you like zany huh
be real quirky hey dude the National
Park Service is kind of cool yeah they
have a sense of humor and that makes me
want to go to park exactly I feel like
during covid so many people that never
been Outdoors started going out because
there was a huge Trend dude we did it
there was there's been so many people
getting like [__] up hiking oh yeah
well there are people that go out that
really should just read first and then
yeah you can get attacked by wild
animals yeah they're hungry all the time
they can just kill a they're not gonna
never not be hungry they're friendly
though I watch cartoons and they just
seem nice and jolly yeah but even Winnie
the Pooh sometimes when he don't have
his honey brother gets Scrappy every
year too a hiker gets or like a jogger
gets attacked by a mountain lion here
yep every [__] year yeah a mountain
lion and there's always some [__] who
gets lost
it was like I'm going hiking I'll be
right back and then they're [__] you
know eight days later they find a
skeleton
[Laughter]
around around this time last year our
our friend's dad Mike's song's Dad
[__] got lost yeah in the woods
oh he made it he made it he wasn't a
skeleton dog he was out there for like
three days in like the snow we thought
we thought he would be dead five days
away from being turned into a skeleton
that's lucky but he made a fire and [__]
man versus well you know you know who
doesn't make a fire who people get
turned into the skeletons yeah the
seventh day they got a little too
curious for their own good yeah they are
too cute yeah dude I mean just imagine
like stepped on the wrong time
click
is there a monkey
holding definitely not the pentate man I
wonder if that [__] happens in Hawaii
where people go in the jungle and then
they get lost and they can't come back
and they die because I'm like dude it's
not that far have you heard about that I
mean it's it's
mountains to the Sea so there's antes
getting bitten by monk seals in the
water it's true attack
oh [__] amongst those [__] you up like
that oh I'll show you a video oh [__]
and they when they bite they bite with
anger like unprovoked they'll just start
well she had her her cub on the beach or
somewhere around in the water yeah I saw
one where a lady was just swimming uh
this was in Oahu recently yeah and then
the [__] seal bitter and everyone's
like you idiot you deserved it but I
guess from her view she didn't know well
she went over the ropes and the signs
that said
they got signs everywhere everywhere
cause I know that I know like I get it
if you get drowned or whatever right but
then when you're in the jungle and like
you can see [__] Waikiki you see the
towers and [__] and I'm like how you get
lost yeah yeah well sometimes people
like visitors come and they stat they
near the ocean they go to places that
I'm just like what more visually could
you see from that vantage point just
trying to put myself there that you
can't see from right here yeah you can't
it says it doesn't never make sense and
then they get swept out I'm like
yeah oh I think that they're just not
thinking you're just watching for sure
oh no for sure I don't even yell anymore
before I used to yell then I got in
trouble really yes I said that's what I
thought someone got farther farther yeah
yeah what do they say what will happen
mind your business they just so it's
like all right yeah wow the day after I
proposed to Nikki we went to these
Cliffs with like Kardashian [__] and it
was super boring kind of but then but
when we got there it was super cool this
is Hawaii yeah it took like 45 minutes
to get there her dad's like taking back
roads he's like show us a lot of Scenic
[__] and I'm like whatever bro what
island it was on uh Waikiki okay
and then um so we get to these Cliffs
and then like there's like [__] water
[__] like going like 30 feet over the
thing like hitting the Rocks going
through everything and I was just like
yeah I just got engaged I'm [__] I
just want to go the other way
I want to live my life right now yeah
it's scary yeah it's different because
like growing up in La we have beaches
yeah I've grew up going to the [__]
beaches out here and then once you go to
Hawaii it's a whole different kind of
feeling yeah the from winter to summer
it's a different kind of feeling and I'm
just like what the [__] is this wave
dude I never felt anything like this
before oh yeah it's weird yeah I hear
it's like knee-deep you know what I mean
yeah we're not worried about it yeah
yeah dude and it just crashes and you
can swim out there the the scariest
thing is a Riptide maybe but that
thing's a homeless guy on the beach
we're stepping on a needle in an or HIV
HIV needles kind of sock
it's not all bad though it's all bad you
should move to Vegas sometimes the
needle has to cure
[Music]